[Musique]
bonjour à tous nouveaux débats sur tv 78
en vue du premier tour des élections
municipales du 15 mars prochain durant
la prochaine heure ce sont les candidats
déclarés à la mairie de rambouillet à la
date de ce 8 février 2020 jours
d'enregistrement qui vont pouvoir
exposer leurs programmes pendant une
heure ils sont cinq autour de cette
table pour à peine leur temps de parole
seront chronométrés et nous avons
effectué un tirage au sort avant
l'émission en vue de la première prise
de parole et le sort a voulu que ce soit
vous véronique matillon qui qui parlait
la première vous êtes tête de liste de
rambouillet ensemble vers l'avenir
élu au conseil du conseil municipal vous
êtes adjointe au maire en charge des
affaires scolaires et familiales vous
est notamment soutenu par le maire
sortant l'est républicain marc robert
expliquez nous pourquoi vous souhaitez
le remplacer justement à la mairie de
rambouillet alors bonjour à tous c'est
un gros challenge de remplacer marc
robert il m'a demandé sachant qu'il ne
pouvait pas prétendre à continuer sa
mission actuelle je les prix comme un
vrai signe de confiance et il est vrai
que cette ville de rambouillet me tient
particulièrement à coeur
j'y suis arrivé avec ma famille il y a
un petit peu plus de 20 ans je le dis
souvent par hasard et si j'y suis resté
ça n'est pas du tout par hasard nous
avons trouvé exactement le cadre de vie
que nous souhaitions avoir pour faire
grandir notre famille et c'est une ville
où les habitants sont accueillants où le
cadre de vie est exceptionnelle et au
fur et à mesure de mes missions dans ce
mandat et dans le mandat précédent
je me suis dit qu'il fallait continuer à
pouvoir apporter à rambouillet tout ce
dont on a bénéficié au départ à notre
arrivée
donc c'est dans ce cadre là que je me
dis que après tout il faut agir et
lorsqu'on nous donne cette possibilité
là il faut y aller
philippe chevrier vous êtes
deuxième à prendre la parole vous êtes
tête de liste de stop aux taxes
conseiller municipal vous aussi mais
d'opposition vous êtes également
conseiller régional on vous connaît pour
être l'ancien membre
un ancien membre du front national dont
vous avez présidé la section locale dans
les yvelines jusqu'en 2017
vous avez écrit ensuite votre parti le
front libéré pourquoi vous voulez
devenir maire de rambouillet vous aussi
et bien parce que j'ai pas été très
content de la manière dont ça s'est
passé pendant les six ans passés et là
je crois que d'ailleurs il faut qu'on
fasse ce bilan parce que c'est important
de faire ce bilan pour savoir d'où on
part
avant de parler de propositions et le
thème parce que sinon ça voudrait dire
que tout ce qu'on promet c'est en fait
des augmentations de taxes fait donc ce
bilan pour moi il est extrêmement
négatif autant d au plan des compétences
parce que à chaque fois que j'ai posé
des questions à l'exécutif au maire il
s'est redit s'est retourné vers les
services pour avoir les réponses ce que
considère comme pas normal je crois que
les gens sont élus pour avoir la
responsabilité de la gestion de la
mairie et ils doivent être en capacité
de répondre aux questions de
l'opposition ça n'a pas été le cas
et aussi en matière de finances en
matière de finance à être une
catastrophe
je crois que on a atteint des sommets en
matière fiscale
on est on a cru la fiscalité de 26% en
six ans ce qui est énorme sur une
fiscalité qui était déjà très importante
et dans un pays où malheureusement on
est tous très fiscalisés ça devient
intolérable
le deuxième point on a presque frôlé la
faillite en 2018 avec un surendettement
ou sur l'introduction forcément le temps
de parole serait ce du débat c'est pour
que vous soyez
j'espère que vous n'allez pas prendre de
mon temps à les y est donc il ya
surendettement il ya eu un
surendettement un très important 2008
heureusement n'est revenue mais on a
frôlé la faillite avec 37 millions de
dettes on a ponctionné sur le fonds de
roulement de 7 millions et demi bref
tout ça à cause d'investissements
beaucoup trop lourd pour les moyens de
la commune et parce qu'on n'a pas voulu
faire les économies qu'il fallait à
paussac en particulier sur le personnel
david jutier c'est à vous de prendre la
parole vous êtes la tête de liste de
rambouillet en commun élus d'opposition
ont ces municipales depuis 2014
vous êtes membre d'europe écologie les
verts aussi soutenu par génération le
parti animalistes et génération écologie
première question aussi à vous pourquoi
vous voulez devenir maire de rambouillet
tout simplement parce que parce que
j'aime cette ville que c'est une ville
magnifique qui a énormément d'atouts un
très fort un très fort potentiel que
comme vous l'avez rappelé je m'y
investis depuis désormais six ans au
sein du conseil municipal depuis
beaucoup plus longtemps
depuis que je suis arrivé avec ma
famille sur sur rambouillet et parce que
aujourd'hui je considère que la
politique qui est
menés sur rambouillet ne va pas dans le
sens de l'histoire et que nous ce que
nous voulons avec ce collectif avec
cette liste qui vous l'avez rappelé
s'appelle rambouillet en commun c'est
faire toutes et tous ensemble une amorce
vers la transition écologique la
transition sociale dont rambouillet a
besoin mettre en place les services qui
manque cruellement à rambouillet on en
parlera tout à l'heure en matière de
santé en matière de déplacements bref
rambouillet c'est une ville que j'aime
c'est une ville dans laquelle je me sens
bien et c'est une ville dont je suis
certain qu'elle va pouvoir se développer
dans le sens de mieux vivre et dans le
sens de la transition écologique qui est
le sens de l'histoire on a besoin
d'aller dans ce dans ce sens là et c'est
pas du tout ce que la municipalité
sortante à a mis en place on en débattra
tout en reparlera en temps
effectivement jean marc seiler vous êtes
tête de liste de rambouillet à gauche
vivante et solidaire seul candidat à ne
pas être élu au conseil municipal vous
n'êtes pas pour autant novice en
politique puisque vous avez été adjoint
au maire de clamart dans les
hauts-de-seine pendant plus de dix ans
pourquoi avoir envie cette fois-ci de
devenir maire de rambouillet alors avant
de dix ans de personnaliser un peu sur
moi même je voudrais rappeler un petit
peu comment comment on en est venu c'est
à dire que la liste heures embrouiller à
gauche vivante et solidaire est parti
d'abord de la discussion avec les gens
dans les quartiers on a fait plusieurs
quartiers et puis on s'est rendu compte
que beaucoup de gens dit il vagues et
une liste à gauche et ils ont posé
beaucoup de problèmes sur bon la voirie
sur la démocratie sur des choses comme
ça et c'est comme ça que petit à petit
donc cette liste ses montées et puis
après bon effectivement j'ai été désigné
comme tête de liste
je pense probablement 1,6 par rapport à
mon expérience qui apportent quelque
chose pour l'ensemble est donc c'est
dans ce sens
la plupart de ceux qui sont sur la liste
sont engagés politiquement syndicalement
ou associatives ans et donc il ya une
vraie demande
deux d'être collectif et de travailler
collectivement sur la ville tout le
monde aime bien ça je pense que monde va
le dire donc c'est pareil à aucun
problème si je suis venu je pense que
c'est aussi parce que ça nous plaisait
beaucoup et on voit qu'il ya des choses
à faire et c'est en ce sens avec le gros
défi aujourd'hui c'est que les villes
comme les départements tout ça ne
peuvent plus continuer comme avant
il faut prendre en compte la question de
l'écologie plus fort sur des
constructions sur des choses comme ça
parce que il ya des gros besoins là
dessus agile suite vous vous terminer ce
premier tour de table vous êtes tête de
liste de génération rambouillet
également élu au conseil municipal vous
avez quitté justement lié à la majorité
il ya un peu plus d'un an dont il y a un
an tout juste plus tôt pour ces
élections vous avez été investis
personnellement par la république en
marche soutenue aussi par le modem vous
est le suppléant d'un point de vue
national de la députée de la 10e
circonscription aurore bergé
dites nous pourquoi enfin vous voulez
devenir maire de la ville de rambouillet
faut pas oublier aussi les autres un
choix aussi soutenu par agir par l'ue
des oeufs et les mouvements les clés je
crois qu on partage tout le même
sentiment on cite une ville que j'aime
j'y suis né j'ai passé toute mon enfance
dans un quartier quartier de la louvière
car maman on y vit toujours c'est un
attachement très fort je suis impliqué
aussi dans la vie associative depuis
très longtemps dans ces deux villes a et
j'ai effectivement effectuer le
plusieurs mandats de niveau communal et
communautaire donc c'est une ville qui a
dû s'y attacher je connais très bien la
volonté de nous engager dans cette
démarche-là a été tout simplement que
j'ai assumé le fait de faire partie de
ces équipes municipales il ya un an mais
j'ai fait un choix le choix était de
dire que je vous pouvez faire autrement
c'est une ville et je crois que tout le
monde partage ce constat qui a un
potentiel extraordinaire parce
l'emplacement par son environnement
il ya un certain nombre de choses et
d'action que l'on doit mettre en place
alors que ce soit par rapport à la
démocratie participative par rapport au
jeu de la transition écologique des
choix qu'on n'a pas fait et des choix
qu'on a fait peut-être certains
timidement donc l'idée c'est de faire
des choix beaucoup plus prononcée et de
tendre vers un cap clair net et partagée
par le plus grand des rambolitains d'en
but
voilà pour ce premier tour de table se
rappelle que nous avons respecté l'ordre
du tirage au sort effectué avant cette
émission que c'est dans l'ordre inverse
que vous pourrez conclure cette émission
première thématique qui va structurer ce
débat la préservation de l'environnement
sujet majeur bien sûr dont tout le monde
se saisit aujourd'hui et encore plus à
rambouillet qui est une ville connue et
reconnue pour sa qualité de vie son
cadre de vie c'est une ville verte
elle est entouré par une forêt éponyme
alors quelles sont vos propositions pour
conserver ce cadre et qui fait beaucoup
d'envieux je tiens aussi à vous rappeler
que nous aborderons ensuite la question
des mobilités donc vous pouvez laborde
et déjà mais nous en parlerons plus
calmement dans quelques quelques minutes
on débute avec vous jean marc seiler
quelles sont vos propositions pour
conserver le cadre de vie à rambouillet
et peut-être l'améliorer encore
mais en fait que je lisais un peu tout à
l'heure j'ai parlé de l'écologie
effectivement c'est un gros souci
puisque on a des échéances qui arrivent
et une situation qui est quand même très
inquiétante et donc il faut le seule
chose c'est que il faut que ce soit
couplé aussi avec toutes les questions
sociales donc à la fois on doit prendre
des mesures en termes d'écologie et en
même temps des mesures en terme social
parce que bien souvent de toute manière
ce sont les catégories les plus
défavorisées qui sont le plus victimes
des conséquences écologiques et en même
temps
c'est aussi eux qui peuvent être
concernées est mobilisé pour pour faire
vraiment des changements dans ce domaine
donc c'est un point important cette
question d'environnement à rambouillet
on bénéficie d'un point de vue nature et
patrimoine d'un déjà de un environnement
agréable et qui ça je pense que tout le
monde sera d'accord aussi pour pour dire
qu'il faut le préserver mais je pense
qu'il faut aussi aller au delà dans ce
que l'on fait donc on a listé un certain
nombre de mesures notamment se servir
des règles de l'urbanisme avec le plan
local d'urbanisme qui fera sûrement
revoir pour introduire de nouvelles
règles sur les économies d'énergie sur
les constructions veiller au respect des
règles par les constructeurs il ya
matière à faire dans ce domaine
sur les transports la mobilité on en
parlera mais c'est quand même un point
très important
la question des services publics parce
que les services publics c'est la
proximité est automatiquement il faut
qu'on est en présence
justement les circuits courts c'est pas
seulement pour ça pour s'alimenter c'est
aussi pour se renseigner pour avoir des
services à la mairie pour avoir des
services la poste
on a quand même eu la fermeture enfin le
déplacement de de la poste un petit
bureau à la clairière temps de parole
sans préciser si les mains merci
beaucoup mais est en fait je sais un
petit peu
j'avais prévu et donc à les services
publics pour nous c'est aussi quelque
chose d'important
on a un hôpital donc là on en parlera
aussi dans un autre un peu plus loin
dans un autre thème en espérant qu'on
ait le temps et donc voilà je pense que
il ya d'autres propositions mais si vous
me lâcher toute façon les thématiques
sont transversales donc vous pourrez
parler des sujets comme vous comme vous
le souhaitez véronique matignon si j'ai
vu dans votre programme que vous
souhaitiez limiter l'étalement urbain
pour préserver les champs et les forêts
qui entourent qui entourent la ville est
ce que c'est ce point principal pour
préserver l'environnement ce qu'il y en
a d'autres
alors il y en a d'autres miss et c'est
vraiment le point principal
effectivement tout le monde s'accorde à
dire que nous avons un environnement est
exceptionnel la forêt les champs au
milieu de la ville je rappelle que pour
passer du centre ville vers le quartier
de la clairière nous passons à travers
des chants ou des agriculteurs
continuent à cultiver
il est important de préserver ses terres
de ne pas urbaniser sur ses terres comme
le disait monsieur seiler effectivement
c'est avec le plan local d'urbanisme que
nous pouvons travailler
il est déjà établi dans ce sens si une
révision doit se faire il faut qu'elle
se fasse toujours dans ce sens avec le
schéma de cohérence territoriale qui ce
qui appuie je rappelle aussi que la
ville de rambouillet est maintenant
intégrée dans le parc naturel régional
ça aussi c'est un frein à cette sueur
urbanisation sur des terres agricoles
donc effectivement c'est un sujet
important
je pense que les rangs bulletin ils sont
très très attaché il faut que l'on
continue dans ce sens là l'urbanisation
actuelle se fait effectivement sur le
centre ville
ça n'est pas étonnant pour pouvoir
protéger et puis l'environnement c'est
aussi tout ce qui se passe au niveau de
l'agriculture
il faut que l'on accompagne aussi les
agriculteurs vers ces transitions qui
sont en train de se passer
je le disais des terres agricoles sont
en en plein dans notre centre ville
quasiment un petit peu juste à côté mais
en tous les cas permet de cette
transition c'est aussi les circuits
courts c'est aussi pouvoir ramener des
marchés avec des producteurs locaux
et puis tout le travail qui peut être
fait et qui a déjà débuté sur les
restaurations scolaires en permettant
effectivement petit à petit
l'introduction de plus en plus
importante du bio et surtout des
circuits courts et de
l'approvisionnement sur ces circuits
courts david jutier c'est forcément un
thème qui vous est cher vos propositions
importantes sur ce sujet là alors moi je
suis très heureux pour commencer que
tout le monde se saisissent de
l'écologie ça montre bien l'importance
de cette thématique et la prise de
conscience de tout le monde
après l'écologie il ya ceux qui en
parlent
et il ya ceux qui en font je suis très
heureux d'entendre madame matillon
parler de la préservation des terres
agricoles puisque pour préserver les
terres agricoles lors du dernier mandat
j'ai été obligé de faire un recours en
justice contre le projet porté par votre
équipe qui voulait urbaniser en
périphérie de rambouillet justement pour
installer un village de la voiture sur
des sur des terres agricoles
donc il ya les paroles et les actes et
puis surtout l'écologie c'est pas juste
un petit catalogue de mesures un petit
peu de bio par là un petit peu de
deux voitures électriques par si
l'écologie telle que moi je la conçois
sur le territoire de rambouillet du sud
yvelines c'est avant tout la
structuration du territoire pour
s'engager dans la transition
et ça veut dire regardez les choses
clairement quel est le poste le plus
émetteur de gaz à effet de serre
aujourd'hui sur notre territoire c'est
le chauffage des logements et des
bâtiments
eh bien il faut accompagner les
bailleurs sociaux il faut accompagner
les habitantes et les habitants pour
rénover énergétiquement leur logement en
particulier pour les ménages les plus
modestes il ya des dispositifs
départementaux il ya des dispositifs de
l'ademe qui permettent de le faire et
qui aujourd'hui ne sont pas activés sur
sur rambouillet il faut ensuite regarder
quel est le deuxième poste le plus
émetteur on en parlera ce sont les
transports donc évidemment favoriser la
pratique du vélo sécurisé la marche à
pied dans de rambouillet qui souvent
très très compliqué il faut également
permettre le covoiturage quotidien dans
les trajets domicile travail
il y avait eu une tentative assez
malheureuse de la part du conseil
d'agglomération qui a été avorté parce
qu'apple de de suivi donc tout ça ça
doit prendre place dans un plan climat
air énergie territorial l'écologie c'est
quelque chose qui doit structurer notre
action et c'est pas simplement un petit
catalogue de mesures qui viennent les
unes à la suite des autres
gilles tweet vous êtes un peu en retard
sur le temps de parole mais c'est normal
vous n'avez parlé qu'une fois vos
propositions là dessus peut-être
répondre aussi puisque vous étiez dans
la majorité municipale il ya encore peu
oui tout à fait il ya eu il ya eu alors
il ya eu des titres certaines décisions
on peut imaginer aussi qu'elle n'était
pas non plus je veux dire très vive et
en tout cas là la halle le
positionnement qu'on a eu dans cette
équipe était pas le très mal marguerite
et pas spécialement le marqueur vers ça
j'en conviens au delà il faut aussi
avoir une approche je veux dire
territoriales sur cette dimension là on
peut pas à réfléchir remblier fait
partie d'une agglo de 36 communes on
peut pas jeunes ont pu décider seul dans
son coin
donc il est bien évident que c'est un
débat qu'il faut avoir je veux dire à
différents niveaux la première
fautivement sur un plan local
le deuxième niveau sur un plan
territorial mais j'attire est simplement
effectivement la tension qui a il ya
aussi lieu quand on parle de
l'environnement il ya le compte on parle
de rambouillet en général il ya
différents rambouillet est bien évident
que la perception qu'on peut avoir des
envies
mon dans les quartiers de la louvière de
rousset ou 0 plombiers sont peut-être
pas tout à fait les mêmes donc là aussi
il ya des travaux à l'investissement à
faire il ya des quartiers gira
privilégié sur lequel il faut réinvestir
sedan sur ces thématiques là qui
aujourd'hui font tout simplement défaut
ça c'est à prendre la chose la deuxième
directive mans de portée je veux dire un
supporter un projet au niveau
territorial
tout à l'heure on parlait enfin on parle
actuellement aussi de todd développement
d'environnements c'est aussi du
déplacement et du déplacement par
exemple si on veut que rambouillet soit
toujours aussi attractif de faire venir
les gens du territoire les habitants du
territoire
si la réfléchir ensemble pardon sur les
aires de stationnement je veux dire
partager
donc ça c'est pas une décision que l'on
peut prendre sol si une décision que
l'on doit dur partagés au niveau du
territoire
c'est ça l'axé jus dire aux écoles une
charges de centralité sur la ville qui
fait que beaucoup de deux collégiens et
vos colis siens qui sont sur le
territoire viennent sur mouillé c'est
l'accès à la gare c'est l'accès à
différentes infrastructures type stades
infrastructures publiques donc si vous
êtes fait avoir vraiment une vue macro
et de le monter d'un cran pour pouvoir
je veux dire pour me dire 'je aborder
cette question là où une des questions
se dit comment enfin enfin donc tu vois
ça sera le cheval de bataille c'est dès
2022 la réinternalisation la gestion de
la cuisine centrale
il n'est pas question de faire un procès
des entreprises de restauration
collective
le projet n'est pas là c'est
qu'aujourd'hui si on veut avoir une
parfaite maîtrise sur les achats sur la
transformation la distribution des repas
il faut ré internaliser cette activité
qui d'ailleurs se fait je veux dire dans
d'autres communes avec une maîtrise de
coûts parfaite et on peut même imaginer
pas imaginer en tout cas probables appui
que les coûts sont moindres qui ne sont
par rapport à l'externalisation philippe
chevrier vos propositions sur sur cette
thématique vous pourrez ensuite répondre
vous êtes libre aussi de solliciter pour
prendre la parole philippe février sur
sur la préservation de l'environnement
donc je veux rebondir sur ce que venait
de dire monsieur schmitt
effectivement
il faut il faut regarder les choses dans
son ensemble avec le territoire et c'est
très important bond rambouillet s'est
pas vraiment là en france où se posent
des problèmes d'environnement mais je
sais que vous avez reçu cette thématique
avec beaucoup de plaisir mais moi il me
semble que si demain à rambouillet ya
des problèmes d'environnement il faudra
s'inquiéter beaucoup de la situation
parisienne par exemple loyers et de la
région parisienne
bon cela dit cela dit il ya quand même
des choses à faire
je constate par exemple dans certains
quartiers monsieur schmitt que le disais
il ya par exemple montre des choses et
il manque des aires de jeu particulier
pour les enfants
j'ai vu que dans les nouveaux nouvelle
résidence on prévoyait des petites aires
de jeux etc
mais il n'ya pas vrai table mende
efforts de la municipalité en direction
des enfants je constate donc il faut
faire ces choses-là c'est vrai que les
façades sont un petit peu triste j'ai
entendu parler de végétalisation des
façades pourquoi pas j'y suis assez
favorable mais effectivement ce qu'il
faut faire et là je rebondirai sur ce
que disait monsieur jutier il faut faire
des économies d'énergie c'est essentiel
donc sur tous les bâtiments municipaux
sur surtout les logements sociaux
il faut aider effectivement les
bailleurs les locataires pour faire en
sorte que leur logement ne soient plus
des passoires thermiques
ça c'est essentiel voilà et bien entendu
je terminerai en disant sur les points
forts de rambouillet c'est à dire le
château le parc du château la forêt tout
ça me semble très bien mais c'est pas
suffisamment mis en valeur une fois par
an il ya un feu d'artifice sur dans le
parc du château
mais le reste de l'année on n'y fait
rien et donc plus de festivités que les
rambolitains s'approprie tous tous eu
tout ce parc est magnifique
véronique matillon vous souhaitiez je
souhaitais répondre effectivement et
puis apporter des précisions quant on
parle d'environnement et quand on parle
effectivement des bailleurs sociaux
il est quand même à noter que sur ce
mandat les bailleurs sociaux qui sont
des partenaires très important
avec la ville ont démarré des travaux
d'envergure justement pour la rénovation
est entre autres énergétique 461
logements ont été réhabilités à ce
niveau là ça n'est pas suffisant
effectivement il faut que l'on continue
à accompagner ses bailleurs sociaux dans
ce sens là ces 16 millions déjà d'euros
qui ont été investis sur ce thème là
c'est important et en effet il faut
continuer quand on parle des différents
quartiers
je pense aussi au parc de groulx s'est
par exemple qui est un lieu où les
d'abord c'est un lieu convivial où on
peut se promener mais c'est aussi un
lieu un lieu pardon où la biodiversité
est très important il faut le savoir
lily à des actions qui sont mises en
place qui ne se voit pas forcément
c'était aussi un petit souci de
communication que l'on doit à revoir sur
la prochaine mandature jean-marcel à ce
que voulaient réagir sachant que le
temps de parole est assez avancé déjà
juste je pense que on dit rambouillet un
environnement mais je pense que toutes
les villes tout le monde doit y est y
penser parce que c'est pas une question
qui concerne que ceux qui ont des
problèmes de pollution ou autre c'est
une question qui concerne tout le monde
sur cette planète donc je pense que ça
doit être pris en compte dans toutes les
villes et sur l'aspect des logements
hockey l'énergie sur le logement social
sur les bâtiments municipaux mais aussi
justement par l'intermédiaire du plan
local d'urbanisme sur les constructions
privées qui vont qui va se faire c'est
très important de prévoir déjà ça aussi
on voit que tout est lié
sur le temps de parole jean schmitt et
david j'utilise est important est ce que
vous les gardez le temps pour la
prochaine thématique ou réagir encore
sur la préservation de l'environnement
david jutier oui quelque chose que
j'avais pas effectivement le temps
d'aborder ces
toute la question de l'alimentation et
de l'agriculture
ça fait très longtemps que l'on demande
à ce que plus de bio soient introduits
dans les cantines c'est possible de le
faire à coût constant on a des exemples
de villes qu'ils ont mis en place les
coûts à paris 2e 25000 personnes même
taille que rambouillet sont même
inférieurs à ce que nous on a avec
sodexo aujourd'hui à rambouillet et
effectivement il faut ré internaliser
comme le propose désormais effectivement
gilles schmitt même si j'ai schmidt
avait pas forcément réagi positivement
lorsque nous on l'avait proposé au cours
de cette mandature mais c'est bien
d'évoluer sur ce sur ce point ça montre
que l'écologie est vraiment le moteur de
cette de cette campagne
réinternalisation des dés de la
préparation des repas
pas seulement parce que ce sera meilleur
pour ce qu'il y aura dans l'assiette
mais aussi parce que ça permet de
développer l'ensemble d'une filière
maraîchère agricole en bio respectueuse
de l'eau des sols de l'air de des
habitations qui sont qui sont autour
et donc quand je vous disais que
l'écologie doit vraiment être le le
guide de ce prochain mandat
la ré internalisation des repas de la
fabrication des repas pour la
restauration collective doit être un
levier qui nous permet de développer une
agriculture plus responsable sur
l'ensemble du territoire et c'est ça une
vraie vision écologique et gilles suite
en 40 secondes si vous pouvez rebondir
peut-être ou peut-être pour l'équilibré
des temps de parole du taf et david
levien me donne induite je tiens à me
jauger de qualité dans un premier temps
philippe chevriot maman pourquoi vous
nous parlez pas du vélo parce que
maintenant les anticiper sur la suite du
débat c'est la prochaine thématique
j'ai eu peur j'ai aussi reçu dans le jeu
mais très rapidement effectivement david
itié ils voient que le fait qu'ils aient
jeté dans une équipe il ya pas fait ce
choix là mais quand on les habille type
on est solidaire dont je me suis trouvée
solidaire parents et de de ce choix là
je vais toujours 2,2 dans un second
temps je te remercie la laddh dans votre
var monsieur effectivement vous fait pas
que j'ai évolué dans ce sens car tous
avant je le pratique sur un plan
professionnel depuis huit ans donc c'est
un sujet que je connais relativement
bien effectivement il y aura toute une
il ya tout un travail à mener avec bien
sûr les agriculteurs passer au bio et
c'est une chose mais si c'est toute une
filière installés sur des faux le
circuit court sert lui l'agriculture
raisonnée
ça mettra un peu de temps mais
effectivement il faut tendre vers ça on
va on va poursuivre ce débat sur sur la
police il est justement j'avais lancé
parfaitement pour la suite du débat
envoyé est une ville quand même assez
éloignée du coeur économique de
l'agglomération parisienne vélo
transport voiture il ya beaucoup de
sujets beaucoup de possibilités de
déplacement aujourd'hui on va commencer
avec véronique matière puisque vous êtes
un peu en retard en temps de parole
quelles sont vos propositions sur ce
sujet précisément pour pour la
circulation la mobilité alors la
mobilité effectivement comme le dit
monsieur chevrier ça fait aussi partie
de l'environnement et cette qualité des
mobilités et est un sujet qu'il faut
vraiment prendre à bras le corps pour
cela
nous avons deux projets aidés par action
coeur de ville et déjà c'est un plan
d'action mis en place par l'état pour
aider les cautions ville et un est un
plan mis en place par l'état dans
laquelle plusieurs villes ont été
finalement invité à participer 222
rambouillet a travaillé sur le
territoire fait partie
il faut effectivement s'appuyer dessus
et à ce titre là tout le quartier gare
sera revue parce que c'est aussi un
noeud important au niveau de la
circulation dans rambouillet il faut
s'attaquer à tout ce quartier gare quand
on dit quartier gare on ne pense pas que
par bigard au côté rue sadi carnot mais
aussi la gare routière et faire en sorte
que toutes les mobilités puisse y
parvenir de façon fluide et fluidifier
déjà ce noeud pour pouvoir rpt
dispatcher la circulation sur les
quartiers environnants et s'attacher
justement pour que bien entendu
l'automobile puisse arriver parce que on
nous n'en sommes pas encore nous
avançons et je pense que la société va
avancer vers moins de voitures dans les
centres villes
toujours est il que pour le moment il ya
toujours la voiture tout de même mais
favoriser les mobilités avec les
transports en commun et bien sur le vélo
et les piétons qu'il ne faut pas oublier
toutes les mobilités douces en fait ne
sont pas que le vélo mais effectivement
les piétons les mamans avec les
poussettes les personnes porteuses de
handicap avec des fauteuils et puis la
trottinette qui arrivent aussi il faut
pas l'oublier donc en fait vraiment
refaire dans ce centre ville un quartier
qui va permettre à près de 2 d'envoyer
les toutes les mobilités vert vers les
autres quartiers et créer des liens et
ccc rupture qu'il y a entre le centre
ville et les différents quartiers c'est
un sujet sur lequel il faut que nous
nous travaillons dès le début du mandat
philippe chevrier parmi les parmi vos
propositions sur les mobilités vous
voulez créer un parking souterrain en
ville mais ken que n'avons nous pas fait
ça depuis trente ans cela fait trente
ans que j'ai connus rambouillet et les
rues sont exactement les mêmes qu'il y a
trente ans rien n'a été fait on va dire
de stationnement en matière de
circulation rien alors moi ce que je
propose c'est un plan global global de
circulation et de stationnement pour
rambouillet qui inclut d'abord les
piétons ensuite les vélos les
trottinettes les automobiles et aussi
des transports en commun où il ya
beaucoup de choses à dire effectivement
des bus électriques bien sûr mais aussi
une tarification à revoir et en
particulier pour les personnes comme
avait fait pourquoi donc les enfants les
personnes d'un certain âge qui devraient
avoir accès au bus gratuitement bien
ceci inclut bien sûr la création d'une
halle sur la place de la mairie avec un
parking souterrain pour couvrir ce
marché qui est aujourd'hui et d'un
marché en plein air et en été c'est très
bien mais en hiver c'est une catastrophe
bien mais ça c'est vrai aussi depuis 30
ans bon
on parle de vos six de piétonniser la
rue principale je suis assez favorable
mais ça doit se regarder avec les
commerçants et puis ça doit s'inscrire
inclure aussi dans ce plan et dernier
point qui doit s'impliquer dans ce plan
c'est ce que vous avez évoqué ses terres
les accès à la gare que je considère
comme absolument scandaleux puisque
effectivement il ya trente ans que ça
dure il ya trente ans que toute la
région vient prendre le train ici à
rambouillet qu'il n'y a pas moyen de se
garer que c'est une catastrophe absolue
que les gens se garent n'importe où et
que rien n'a été fait depuis trente ans
et c'est là il faut que donc un cabinet
dont c'est la spécialité se mettent en
place pour travailler sur ce sujet et
croyez moi non seulement non seulement
il a travaillé sur ce sujet mais toutes
les semaines il va venir me voir pour me
dire où il en est de la progression de
ces travaux et je lui donne six mois
pour pour finaliser trois scénarios sur
lesquels nous que nous choisirons en
commun avec les rambolitains car ce sera
un exercice de démocratie directe david
jutier sur la problématique des
mobilités oui effectivement la mobilité
à rambouillet sont un gros problème
aussi bien au sein de la ville que pour
aller travailler et revenir et revenir
sur la ville la première priorité au
sein de la ville c'est de mettre en
place un plan de réfection des voiries
qui soit ambitieux et surtout qu'ils
soient réguliers aujourd'hui à
rambouillet on a des voiries qui ont 20
ans 30 ans sur lesquels tous les travaux
nécessaires n'ont pas été fait et on se
retrouve obligée d'investir énormément
donc il faut faire cet investissement il
faut ensuite entretenir régulièrement
les voiries parce que entretenir les
voiries effectivement ça permet de
partager l'espace entre la voiture le
vélo et et
également naturellement les piétons à
rambouillet je pense que tout le monde
quasiment à une voiturette
automobilistes à un moment et tout le
monde est au moins un piéton à un moment
et donc sont les deux catégories
principales qui doit se partager
correctement l'espace
et puis évidemment mettre en place un
plan de circulation à vélo qui soit
ambitieux une grande enquête nationale a
été réalisée dont les résultats viennent
de tomber et ils sont sans aucune
surprise très mauvais pour pour
rambouillet aujourd'hui rambouillet
consacre 4 euros par an et par habitant
au développement des circulations
cycliste vous proposons de d'attribuer
25 euros par an et par habitant ce qui
n'est absolument pas quelque chose de
stratosphérique loin de là c'est le
minimum pour faire en sorte que
l'ensemble des circulations vélo en
particulier pour les plus fragiles pour
les enfants aux abords des écoles soient
sécurisés et puis pour les trajets
domicile domicile travail
il faut absolument développer le
covoiturage et ça c'est quelque chose
qui se met en place sur le long terme il
faut des aires de stationnement le
covoiturage
il faut faire tout un travail de réseau
envers les entreprises et les pôles
d'emploi qui sont en dehors de
rambouillet pour sensibiliser et pour
mettre en lien les les personnes qui
peuvent partager des transports dans la
même dans la même voiture c'est quelque
chose de fondamental et gilet chemise
sur les mobilités vous il a été évoqué
la question des de transport en commun
gratuit pour les plus jeunes c'est l'une
de vos propositions les bus gratuit pour
les moins de 18 ans seulement 18 ans le
tout à fait le sur le projet de mobilité
fait la thématique de mobilité
effectivement il faut commencer par la
chaire pour les fondamentaux c'est de
refaire la voirie ça va de soi mais
d'éviter d'avoir une voirie qui serait à
la fois un petit peu pour les un petit
peu pour les autres crois qu'il va
falloir qu'on fasse des choix et les
choix vont être la place effectivement
du pied du piton entrepôts mieux mais
aussi du vélo et la voiture on s'accorde
à dire aujourd'hui tous les spécialistes
s'accordent à dire que d'avoir fait tout
le monde sent même espace ne fonctionne
pas ça veut dire aussi qu'il faut revoir
je veux dire à travers le plan local de
déplacement mais aussi au niveau de
l'organisme va falloir aussi qu'on
revoie les le stationnement parce qu'on
pourra pas peut-être avoir autant de
stationnement et faire une place au vélo
tout ça le même temps je pense
particulièrement l'accès garde qui nous
paraît fondamental
l'axé aussi aux écoles en toute sécurité
on voit aussi par exemple on voit bien
que ce plan le tient de circulation les
gens qui veulent s bi rambouillet ça
nous amène à faire un tour quand vous
êtes à placer flex for a été obligé de
faire un tour complètement long beach et
et il suffirait enfin il suffire en tout
cas une des possibilités serait de
remonter la rue charles dans d'autres
s'en sont moindres pour les vélos y
accéder là aussi d'avoir un axe gare
lycée gère beaucoup plus fluide et vous
pardon oui oui ces gens-là accélère
disait que c'était la loi
oui c'est la loi mais qui n'étaient pas
appliquées actuellement il n'est pas
vrai elle peut être applicable le
problème c'est que si vous le faites
c'est un peu dangereux parce que c'est
pas signalé j'en ai maintenant mes en
remettra tout ce qu'il faut je veux dire
je reste dans un premier temps
effectivement première étape c'est
effectivement la voirie la deuxième
étape c'est l'axé gare donc à aussi
c'est un sujet qu'il faut porter au
niveau du territoire
parce qu'il n'ya pas que des gens de
rambouillet et puis si d'avoir une
réflexion quand beaucoup plus haute
c'est tout ce toutes les communes qui
ont des gas gas rambouillet le père est
nécessaire d'avoir aussi julien une
approche on parlait tout à l'heure d'une
approche globale une apologie du
territoire comment se déplacent bien sûr
là aujourd'hui on se prête on parle de
la mairie d'angoulême et ça va de soi
mais la responsabilité d'envoyer en
termes de mobilité se porte aussi au
niveau de l'agglo donc dans un premier
temps on refait les war et en
concertation avec les acteurs sont
piétons vers sig liste est bien sûr il
ya embolie teint tout ça dans une
démarche participative petit hic
effectivement il va y avoir un une
réflexion sur le pôle gare bon il est un
petit peu dommage que ce pôle gare n'a
pas été communiqué j'ai un ensemble à la
fois des élus et des embolies temps j'en
ai eu jeudi on a eu l'information et
voit la part de manière julian qui
étaient parlées plus les plus fluides
je vais juste préciser le nom de
l'agglomération suis ici on connaît bien
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines communauté d'agglomération
rambouillet territoire puisque vous
l'avez chacun évoqué jean marc keller
vous aussi la gratuité des transports
c'est dans les première proposition vous
avez dévoilé sur les réseaux sociaux
puis se limitera pas aux
moins de 18 ans mais c'est vrai qu'il
faut il travailler parce que oui c'est
déjà pas mal mais en fait on voit bien
que évidemment c'est un coup tout ça
mais après ça des répercussions très
positives
tout l'été les villes qui ont déjà
essayé comme dunkerque ou autres font le
constat que c'est vraiment très
bénéfique pour pour tout le monde donc
c'est l'essentiel
après il ya toute la question des
transports en commun du réseau de
transport en commun qui nous semblent
besoin d'être vu un petit peu justement
pour un maillage à la fois proche des
gens proches des services
je crois que c'est vous qui avez parlé
des difficultés différents quartiers et
c'est vrai qu'il ya des quartiers des
fois qu'ils sont mal desservis on avait
distribué sur drainant villiers et nous
ont tous fait beaucoup de remarques là
dessus c'est d'ailleurs un des thèmes
qui est venu beaucoup dans les
discussions qu'on a pu avoir dans l'est
dans les quartiers c'est le thème
principal qui revient je pense qu'il
faut le voir dans l'ain tout est à dire
que c'est un peu ce qu'on prévoit nous
c'est à dire toutes les questions la
question du circulation vélo la question
des trottoirs aux piétons
la question de la circulation automobile
à la question des transports en commun
c'est c'est vraiment un gros pôle que la
question des déplacements et il faut le
spécial il faut le prévoir sur on était
pas obligé toujours de payer des
cabinets qui vont travailler là-dessus
prendre avec des années je pense que des
fois aussi avoir cessé bien six mois
dans les services de mairie des fois il
ya des gens très compétents
donc il faut s'appuyer sur eux j'ai les
compétences depuis 30 ans moi j'ai eu
l'expérience sur une grande ville de
plus de 50000 habitants qu' il y avait
beaucoup de gens très compétents et qui
d'ailleurs apprécié beaucoup qu'on leur
donne des responsabilités sans 500 à la
mairie de paris la mairie zot parole
c'est ouais si vous voulez continuer
mais vous aurez forcément moins de temps
pour la seconde donc la question je vais
faire plus vite donc les circulations
vélo c'est quelque chose qui revient
très fort et qui sont pas aux prises et
vous parlez de harwich halles c'est une
zone 30 dans toutes les zones 30 la loi
autorise le contresens cyclables le
problème c'est que moi j'ai déjà fait
c'est pas facile parce que en fait c'est
pas indiqué dans une voiture c'est très
dangereux de l'éducation là c'est très
dangereux parce que c'est pas marqué il
ya des endroits où l'espace est pas
forcément plus grand mais c'est déjà
moins dangereux mais là y'a bon mais
piétons madame madame mations vos rêves
des régions où d'accord vacanciers
question d'équité a lésé juste juste oui
pour revenir sur la gratuité des
transports effectivement vous parlez de
la gratuité de transport je rappelle
juste que ça ne relève pas de la
compétence municipale et que là il y a
quand même le partenaire ile-de-france
mobilité avec lesquels il faut
travailler sur ce sujet là il y avait la
gratuité je le rappelle juste il y avait
la gratuité pour les personnes âgées
à une époque et à l'époque le stif avait
pointé le soin de transformer le
syndicat des transports d'ile-de-france
avait pointé du doigt et avait même
taper sur les doigts de la ville de
rambouillet qui faisait une qui a
cording gratuité alors qu'il n'y avait
pas le droit de le faire donc là encore
il faut travailler on ne peut pas
annoncer de telles mesures sans les
avoir travaillé au préalable et s'être
engagé lorsque ça n'est pas que de notre
compétence dans la volonté de faire je
suis juif et le sujet thiémé change vite
puisque la somme de vos propositions
schappert personnes le transport c'est
une compétence régionale sas a échappé à
personne sauf que le poids la force
publique la force politique c'est d'un
moment de réunir la somme est autour
d'une table et de temps en temps suggéré
des fois aussi d'imposer ou de négocier
pour quelques choses évoluent voilà en
tout cas autrement ça veut dire qu'on
subit il entend qui lui sait pas ce
qu'on attend de la part des élus vous
êtes tous à presque 7 minutes vos à 6,30
vous avez 30 secondes si vous souhaitez
revenir rapidement sur la gratuité des
transports effectivement on peut faire
des promesses
une campagne électorale on va fleurir
effectivement beaucoup d'engagement qui
sont difficilement tenable monsieur
seiler parlait de l'agglomération de
dunkerque et autonome sur ces transports
donc moi la gratuité des transports à
rambouillet j'y suis favorable
pour autant je vais pas promettre que on
va pouvoir rendre les transports
gratuits alors qu'effectivement en ile
de france on est dans une situation
particulière et will de france mobilité
à la compétence transport on va y
travailler
certes je le promets très pas par contre
ce que je peux m'engager a à faire c'est
travailler avec le partenaire transdev
qui assure les transports sur notre
agglomération à ce que des bus circulent
plus tard le soir en particulier le week
end et à ce que des bus circulent le
dimanche parce que lorsque les
transports en commun s'arrête à partir
d'une certaine heure et ben ça bloque
énormément de personnes et qu'est ce
qu'on fait on prend sa voiture et le
dimanche quand on veut emmener les
enfants au match de foot ou que l'on
veut aller se balader dans le parc du
château qu'est ce qu'on fait on prend la
voiture
donc il ya des sujets sur lesquels on
peut agir on peut agir s'ils suivent et
très vite les horaires et d'outrances
theron le maillage
le maillage des transfos sur lequel on
peut travailler sans promettre la
gratuité ni qui s 15 minutes d'émission
seulement vous propose de passer
troisième à la troisième thématique de
ce débat la santé je rappelle que
évidemment nous sommes en direct sur tv
soit 118 que cette émission sera à
retrouver sur tv 78 et aussi sur radio
sensations donc la santé c'est un sujet
donc s'y était notamment pour les
personnes les plus âgées rambouillet
n'est pas encore considérée comme un
désert médical selon les chiffres de
l'union régionale des professionnels de
santé
il y en a une trentaine de médecins sur
la ville mais ce chiffre est en baisse
de 20% sur dix ans et plus de la moitié
de ses médecins ont 55 ans ou plus la
question est donc de savoir comment on
fait pour inverser cette tendance si je
me fie aux temps de parole jean schmitt
vous pouvez commencer sur la question de
la santé vous êtes je crois favorable à
la création d'une maison de santé
je suis d'abord favori je suis je
connais bien l'hôpital j'ai passé
quelques années que évidemment sur
envoyer vous les deux précisé mais il ya
un centre hospitalier tout à fait centre
hospitalier qui fait partie d'un j'ai
acheté d'un groupement hospitalier de
territoire et y repense ptg territoire
et qui a la particularité d'être un des
établissements parti c'est à dire qu'il
ya pas tout à fait sa totale autonomie
ça c'est le contexte sur vos
propositions du coup sûr la santé ça
assez rapidement parce que le temps
s'écoule à servir s'est rapidement d'une
part le maire de rambouillet doit
absolument président du conseil de
surveillance pour envoyer un message
fort
on peut pas jouer a confié cette mission
je veux dire à quelqu'un tire saint
enverra un message fort auprès des
embolies teint auprès des gens d'études
utilise habitants du territoire
il ya auprès des personnels c'est un
triptyque c'est un dossier que l'on doit
mener jeudi avec l'agglo aussi parce que
l'hôpital de rambouillet a été aussi
bâti pour 50000 un bassin de population
de 50000 personnes
donc autant dire à peu près pour
l'ensemble du territoire de l'agglo en
sait quelque chose
enfin c'est une thématique qu'on peut
pas non plus gérer seul c'est une
thématique sur lesquels des élus doivent
prendre toute leur part de
responsabilité à la fois sur un point
effectivement locales sur un plan
territorial mais aussi sur un plan au
niveau du j'ai acheté voilà donc il faut
rendre il faut une bien définis en
commun dhiraj les prestations que l'on
que l'on veut sur ce sujet là est
incertain d'activité effectivement qu'il
faut absolument conserver
j'ai reçus rambouillet les urgences la
mater la pédiatrie il ya un certain
nombre de choses si on d'urgence en
train de va pas trop rentrer dans le
technique mais que l'on de regarder et
aussi s'inscrire sur des filières
d'excellence
je pense tout parent qui ont à la
cardiologie ou sur le territoire on
pourrait déceler identifier
soigné sur un établissement par son de
cloche est de récupérer en soins de
suite
donc c'est des filières d'excellence en
tout cas c'est un une action qu'on doit
mener je veux dire ada au moins à deux
échelles philippe chevrier sur la
question de la santé vous êtes favorable
à la création vous aussi d'une maison de
santé
c'est du vent comme la plupart des
candidats vous avez dit vous avez dit
tout à l'heure que rambouillet n'était
pas encore un désert médical dont les
chiffres mais pas encore en fait et
toute l'île de france est en fait un
désert médical et ça c'est dit et redit
en permanence par valérie pécresse qui a
parfaitement raison et qui fait un
tailleur un excellent travail à la
région je dit en passant et comme je
suis moi même à la commission permanente
de la commission des finances je suis
bien placé pour savoir que la région
finance des maisons de santé dans toute
l'île de france elle le finance comment
on est dans des personnels
administratifs à s'installer justement
dans des maisons de santé il reste
maintenant au maire à faire ce qu'il
doit faire c'est être préempté des
locaux pour les mettre à disposition de
ses médecins à qui ce qui pourrait venir
sur rambouillet leur faciliter la vie
leur trouver des logements
voilà ce que doit faire le maire lille
et la région ile de france fera le reste
et ça peut se faire extrêmement
rapidement et il ya les moyens pour ça
et la volonté politique au niveau de la
région ile de france
david jutier vous est favorable aussi à
l'1 centre de santé je re provôté 1-1 /
parce que c'est vrai aussi absolument
une maison de santé c'est simplement
mettre des locaux à disposition et
faciliter l'installation de médecins
libéraux on voit que c'est pas suffisant
pour attirer des médecins sur
rambouillet il nous faut des médecins
vous c'est un sourire
oui je vais vous expliquer ce qu est un
centre municipal de santé moi je
travaille sérieusement les dossiers je
suis allé en visité à malakoff on a été
reçus par le directeur du centre qui
nous a expliqué qu'elle était là
différents 30 un centre et une une
maison me dit que ce n'était pas encore
un désert médical selon les chiffres moi
ce qui m'intéresse c'est pas les
chiffres c'est ce que vivent au
quotidien les habitants
et aujourd'hui quand on s'installe à
rambouillet on ne peut plus avoir accès
à un médecin généraliste parce que
toutes les patientes m sont complètes
pour avoir un rendez vous chez un
ophtalmologiste c'est des mois
d'attentes un dentiste en urgence c'est
la même chose donc moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est le vécu est pas et pas
les chiffres et donc pour pallier à
cette désertification médicale qu'on
connaît sur rambouillet notre
proposition phare c'est un centre
municipal de santé dans lequel les
médecins sont salariés de la ville les
comptes s'équilibrent entre les salaires
et les rentrées qui sont dues aux actes
l'ensemble des dossiers médicaux sont
partagés le tiers payant est généralisée
et ça ça permet d'une part de consolider
l'activité de l'hôpital parce que ça
désengorge les urgences en permettant à
tout le monde de trouver un tuteur et à
tout moment
un médecin qui vous prend en charge et
ça permet de faire venir sur rambouillet
des médecins kinés faire des ces
derniers équilibrée parce que je vais
j'imagine l'objection ça va coûter cher
je termine parce que c'est ma lisier les
y important est grand temps pour
conclure mais ça permet de faire venir
des médecins qui aujourd'hui ne veulent
plus faire des journées de 20h passé
beaucoup de temps sur de l'administratif
centre municipal de santé ils sont
salariés les comptes sont équilibrés il
se consacre aux soins vos temps de
parole s'est un peu emballé en volley
véronique matillon leur voue le bleu le
nom le nom est différent il voulait
créer une communauté professionnelle qui
arrive territorial de santé est ce que
vous pouvez nous expliquer se prendra
alors la santé vous imaginez bien je
suis de profession infirmière c'est
quand même un sujet qui ne tient
particulièrement à coeur
je rejoins monsieur jutier en disant
effectivement nous ne sommes pas
considérés comme désert médical
les signaux sont quand même commencé à
être au rouge
et j'entends que les nouveaux
rambolitains ne trouve pas l'offre de
soin nécessaire ne serait-ce qu'en
en médecins généralistes la communauté
professionnelle territorial de santé
n'est pas un dispositif municipal c'est
la volonté des professionnels de santé
de sang de s'intéresser ensemble à ce
sujet il y à une association sur la
ville de rambouillet qui s'est montée
qui est assez exceptionnel parce que je
le dis je suis moi-même professionnels
de santé nous avons pu voir autour de la
table toutes les professions de santé se
réunir ce qui est quand même
exceptionnel
ça ne fait pas partie au départ de la
culture des professionnels de santé
et cette association a pour but
justement de pouvoir arriver au
dispositif de la communauté
professionnelle territorial de santé
avec l'appui de l'agencé suggère
régionale de santé
cc pts sont en fait fait pour permettre
que les soins soit accessible en premier
recours et en deuxième recours avec
l'appui de l'hôpital et sur
l'association actuelle nous avons pu
voir que les professionnels de santé
libéraux prennent le sujet en main avec
les professionnels de centres de santé
de l'hôpital donc ce lien ville hôpital
est absolument nécessaire
maison de santé je n'ai rien contre je
pense que il faut vraiment écouter les
professionnels de santé et faire avec
eux l'orque lorsqu'ils en ont besoin et
les salariés pourquoi pas encore faut-il
trouver des médecins qui acceptent
finalement d'être salarié quand on est
au son dans un centre de soins il y a
des obligations alors les libéraux ne
veulent pas forcément on va pas se voir
beaucoup continuent sur cette thématique
jean marc keller et puis la conclusion
ensuite alors les temps de conclusions
seront très déséquilibrée du fait des
temps de parole qu'ils le sont eux aussi
jean marc keller ou s'ils sont de santé
vous rejoignez david gauthier david
jutier déjà bien
développer les centres de municipal de
santé je peux en dire plus je connais
très bien plus malakoff je les fréquente
et et je sais c'est notre proposition
également d'un centre municipal de santé
il a expliqué la différence et c'est
important
je vais aussi parler de l'hôpital c'est
à dire que on a un hôpital à rambouillet
ça c'est une chose très importante on a
d'ailleurs dans notre liste beaucoup de
gens qui font partie du collectif de
défense et de développement de l'hôpital
de rambouillet il faut que cet hôpital
il a les moyens et y compris notre liste
et donc notre si nous sommes élus nous
défendrons et nous ce que vous avez dit
tout à l'heure sur le conseil de
surveillance ça nous paraît évident que
le maire fasse partie du conseil de
surveillance et qu'il intervienne pour
peser sur les choix et les décisions
parce que l'hôpital est en difficulté
pour départ des choix politiques qui ont
été menées depuis pas mal d'années et
donc qu'il faut peser pour inverser la
tendance
juste par rapport aux déserts vous avez
par les déserts médicaux
juste un exemple nous on est arrivé à
deux ans j'ai dû téléphoner à 14
médecins pour trouver une personne qui
accepte s'était posé sans viser les
médecins engagés dans un genre déjà voir
leur janvier la clientèle leur pays une
nouveau patient terminé donc quand même
il ya une vraie préoccupation sur la
ville et vous pouvez voir dans les
réseaux sociaux les gens ils mettent ça
beaucoup en avant
en tout cas on comprend que c'était un
sujet majeur de cette campagne pour
embrouiller la santé on arrive au bout
de cette émission avec le temps de
conclusion qui a valeur de cartes
blanches vous êtes libre de me parler de
la thématique que vous souhaitez on n'a
pas notamment abordé la thématique de
l'attractivité du territoire libre à
vous d'en parler de parler d'eux
d'autres choses on prend l'ordre inverse
de l'introduction sachant qu'il faut
qu'on arrive à peu près à 10 minutes de
temps de parole chacun donc j'ai su me
que vous aurez une minute trente et
david jutier par exemple vous n'aurez
que 30 secondes et gilles smit pour pour
débuter ce tour de conclusion on a
abordé toutes les thématiques du conte à
bord est ce matin font partie fiction de
et moi je suis intimement convaincu que
la volonté politique doit transformer
mesure les choses il ya une attente qui
n'attend extraordinaire des rambo y
tiennent des rôles et 1 on peut la
perdre à lever le constater quand on
fait le porte à porte quand on fait nos
réunions publiques
quand on rencontre les rambos lite est
né un 8 1 sur le marché il ya une
attente d'une attente sur l'immobilité
il y en attente sur la santé il ya une
attente aussi sur les commerces sur la
proximité d'europe de recréer de recréer
du lien que tu as fait et je n'avais que
celui ci avait dans les deux minutes
vous avez entièrement raison et j'assume
complètement écrit et on a effectivement
on s'est même opposé à vos décisions
donc là dessus j'assume complètement
au-delà de ça voilà donc il ya une
formidable opportunité de faire évoluer
cette vie d'affaires change et l'inscrit
aussi dans une dynamique pour les
prochaines années aux parents tout à
l'heure on parlait des transitions
technologiques
il fallait faire des choix judicieux qui
tranche est en tout cas ce qu attendent
les je veux dire les rambos litanie en
bullet 1 c'est la part des élus c'est
des choix clairs d'être précis et qui
s'inscrivent aussi dans le temps
jean-marc seiler vous avez une minute 20
pour conclure donc c'est nous on a
choisi de parler d' un peu du comment
faire parce qu'effectivement c'est
important puisqu'on a des propositions
et aux yeux des habitants il faut dire
un peu que l'on va faire
le premier première chose c'est qu'on a
un volet démocratie participative qui
est très important parce que de plus en
plus il faut que les il faut expliquer
faut informer et faut entendre ce que
les gens ont à dire
on le voit il ya des témoins qui montre
bien que il ya
comment dire défiance vis-à-vis des
institutions notamment avec ce qui s'est
passé les gilets jaunes et compris les
actions qui sont menées où on n'écoute
pas vraiment les revendications on est
droit dans ses bottes et on continue
d'avancer
c'est un moment donné ça risque de se
payer donc il faut vraiment travailler
avec donc on a des grosses propositions
sur des conseils de quartier des maisons
de quartier il doit me restait du temps
encore dix secondes oui et le deuxième
point c'est sur les finances les
finances il ya eu des finances en 5
secondes
oui ça y est c'est passé voilà david
j'utilise désolé monsieur c'est une
question d'équité en plus comme on
couvre pas rambouillet plus qu'on le
peut pour les accords de saint quentin
en yvelines
on doit continuer david jutier 30
secondes grand maximum en trente
secondes pourquoi est-ce que je suis
candidat et pourquoi est ce que il faut
voter pour la liste rambouillet en coma
parce que ça fait six ans que nous
travaillons sur ce territoire que nous
voulons le faire avant celle engagée
dans la transition écologique et que si
on s'appelle rambouillet en commun c'est
parce qu'on peut le faire toutes et tous
ensemble on n'a pas parlé de la
démocratie locale mais pour nous c'est
quelque chose d'extrêmement important
on a deux représentants de la de la
majorité sortante qui aujourd'hui porte
un projet de continuité nous on veut un
projet progressiste un projet de rupture
et donc on veut toutes et tous ensemble
pour les biens communs et en commun
merci philippe chevrier vous avez un peu
plus de temps une minute 40 pour pour
conclure votre carte blanche alors
l'attractivité du territoire très
rapidement la nationale 10 il faut
arrêter il faut arrêter les
embouteillages il faut la passer à
quatre voies il faut plus de démocratie
interne à l'intérieur de rambouillet à
territoire parce que les petits mais on
n'arrive pas les maires de petites
communes n'arrive pas à se faire
connaître il faut plus d'attrait en
matière d'hôtellerie et de restauration
à rambouillet s'est tu suces et c'est
une ville absolument dormantes
aujourd'hui de ce point de vue il
faudrait des choses attractifs comme un
très beau golf par exemple il faudrait
plus d'animation pour les jeunes etc etc
moi ce que je vous dis c'est que je suis
le seul à financer tout ce que je dis
j'ai pas entendu de financement rien moi
je vous dis qu'il faut revenir aux
effective il faut revenir aux effectifs
de 2013 c'est à dire 60 effectif de
moins ça vous fait 3 millions par an dis
donc 18 millions sur l'ensemble de la
mandature mandature et ça vous permettra
de faire effectivement ce qu'il faut
faire pour les voiries j'entends dire
qu'il faut mettre 10 millions je sais
pas encore où ils vont les trouver
les des millions s'ils s'attaquent pas à
ce problème il ya quatre moyens pour
réduire la masse salariale plan de
départs volontaires
ça a déjà été fait dans les yvelines
s'attaquer aux contractuels
il ya 25 % des gens qui sont
contractuels amérique centrale garde ça
c'est ça c'est un problème qui dure
depuis trente ans les retraits alors
ceux qui partent en retraite pour nous
ils n'ont pas besoin d'être remplacés et
enfin la mutualisation avec rambouillet
territoire c'était c'est extrêmement
important
on en parle depuis six ans on ne fait
rien il faut le faire il faut y aller
véronique matillon 40 secondes
alors je suis effectivement de l'équipe
sortante est fier d'en être le projet
que nous portons contrairement à ce que
pense monsieur chevrier est entièrement
financé par ce que nous pouvons nous
appuyer sur un vrai budget je ne
m'attaque pas surtout pas au personnel
et encore moi personnellement j'ai réglé
et je suis dans une continuité certes
mais en innovant vous aura pas échappé
que je suis une femme et que cette
sensibilité changera aussi la façon
d'aborder les choses sur le mandat futur
voilà c'est la fin de cette émission
vous avez les réseaux sociaux les sites
internet et la campagne pour pour vous
répondre éventuellement et mettre les
choses au clair merci à vous 5 d'avoir
participé à ce débat du premier tour des
élections municipales pour embrouiller
cette émission est à revoir sur notre
site internet et nos applications
mobiles et sur à écouter aussi sûr
sensation yvelines laisser les électeurs
en savent un peu plus sur vos programmes
je crois désormais pour rappel le
premier tour aura lieu le dimanche 15
mars
en attendant la campagne se poursuit et
elle est à suivre dans notre journal
quotidien chaque soir à 18 heures et sur
notre site internet et tout le reste de
la journée merci à tous
[Musique]
à